[Applaudissements]
c'est une histoire de transmission du
créol entre l'ancienne et la nouvelle
génération ça passe par la musique d'ici
avec Daniel oir ça passe aussi par la
contribution d'auteur créole venu
d'ailleurs
B Jud Joseph est un écrivain d'origine
haïtienne qui jongle entre le français
et le créole il reconnait prendre
beaucoup plus de plaisir à rédiger en
créole ha mademoiselle voulez-vous
danser quand on parle ça parle avec des
tons ça parle avec des des gestes avec
les mains au visage tout ça et du coup
au fur et à mesure et puis il a il y a
la chansonnette de de l'accent ou des
accents une langue vivante qui se suffit
à elle seule y compris lorsqu'elle
cohabite avec d'autres langues
officielles comme à l'Î Maurice je ne
peux pas réfléchir français je ne peux
pas réfléchir en anglais je suis je peux
facilement être plus à l'aise pour
écrire mes émotions pour faire ressortir
mes
sentiments dans ma langue maternelle il
Maurice Haïti séchel anti Guyane le
Salon du Livre des monondes créole et le
carrefour de la créolité ce weekend à
Saint-Paul moi je parle créole parce que
c'est plus facile
et c'est notre langue
ici et aussi que que toutes les habitud
comme ça parler et écrire en créole est
aujourd'hui indispensable pour péréniser
la langue je pense que le créol a trop
subi du jou du colonialiste et je crois
que qu'il n'y a aucune langue inférieure
à l'autre toutes les langues se valent
et ce ne considère pas ma langue c'est
qu'on ne me considère pas moi en tant
que personne et c'est pour cela que je
milite et malgré les distances
géographique les langues créoles ont
beaucoup de points en commun notamment à
travers les conttes nous on commence par
criquer craquer ailleurs on commencera
par écrire écras on aura les devinettes
partout et quelquefois les mêmes
devinettes dans dans des langues des
langues différentes
bon tout ça tout tout ça nous rapproche
il existe plus de 70 langues créoles
dans le
monde